the White House is blaming North Korea
for a worldwide cyberattack that cost
billions of dollars the Trump
administration says it holds Pyongyang
directly responsible for the wanna cry
attack earlier this year
this comes as North Korea rejects
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson offer
of talks Margaret Brennan is at the
White House market good morning morning
good morning well the White House says
that this attack put lives at risk by
hitting hospitals and rendering useless
more than 230,000 computers and schools
businesses and homes in more than 150
countries and a Wall Street Journal
editorial by homeland security adviser
Tom bass hurt the White House Calls this
widespread attack cowardly costly
careless and indiscriminately reckless
Bossert did not present any evidence but
said the White House does have proof the
malicious software which encrypted data
and demanded payment to recover files
has been traced back to North Korea by
the United Kingdom Microsoft and the
United States now the White House says
hackers and totalitarian governments
should pay a price for their actions and
are calling on other countries to
counter North Korea's ability to conduct
malicious cyber activity by implementing
already existing UN Security Council
sanctions now Bossert will make an
official announcement here at the White
House later this morning in the White
House Nora is already calling for action
to curb Pyongyang's attacks all right
Margaret thank you so much